ضربة انتقامية.
يجب ان نراقب تحركات روسيا.
بوتين يحضر لشيء كارثي. وطائرة
الناتو تتجسس على روسيا
والاوكرانيون يودعون مدينتهم.
وكييف تتدخل بلواء الرد السريع.
امريكا ترفض ارسال هذه القنابل
لاوكرانيا. قبل روسيا للحرب
بمعية روسيا والولايات المتحدة
الامريكية تتحدى الصين وبكين
ترد. ان اعطتها واشنطن الضوء
الاخضر كوريا الجنوبية تقولها
لقد حان وقت الحرب فلتستعد يا
كيم ودمية اردوغان تعرقل انضمام
السويد للناتو والسوريون يرفضون
سلام الاتراك فيما المانيا
تستنجد بالعراق فهل تنقذ بغداد
برلين من ازمتها وفي تونس الشعب
يريد اسقاط النظام.
الانتصار الروسي الذي اغضب
الناتو. بعد حرب طاحنة لقد حان
وقت الوداع. المواطنون الاوكران
يودعون مدينتهم ليبدأ الجيش
الروسي باجلاء سكان مدينة سوليدر
والقرى المجاورة الى مدينة
شختارسك. وبالرغم من النفي
الاوكراني بخسارة معارك سوليدر
فهي وزارة الدفاع الروسية تشيد
بشجاعة قوات فاغنر خلال المعارك
هناك بينما جاء الرد الاوكراني
على ايدي قوات لواء الرد السريع
فورا وذلك قصف مواقع للقوات
الروسية في محيط باخموت. هناك
خرج الناتو معلنا انه سيعيد نشر
انظمة طائرات الانذار المبكر اي
واكس من المانيا ورومانيا
لمراقبة النشاط العسكري لروسيا.
طائرات اي واكس قادرة على مسح
مناطق تصل الى ثلاثمائة وعشرة
الاف كيلومتر مربع ومراقبتها
ويمكنها رصد اي اجسام تطير على
ارتفاعات منخفضة متوسطة ومرتفعة.
لكن هل يحتاج الناتو ان يرصد
تحركات روسيا? رئيس الادارة
العسكرية في كييف. يجيب قائلا
انه لا يستبعد ان تشن روسيا
هجوما جويا جديدا انطلاقا من
بلاروسيا بينما قال زيلينسكي ان
انخراط بلاروسيا الكاملة في
الحرب الى جانب روسيا سيكون خطأ
استراتيجيا خطيرا للغاية. لكن
الخارجية الروسية تعتبر ان
المشتركة مع بيلاروسيا تهدف الى
ردع الاعداء عن القيام باي تصعيد
عسكري. ولم تستبعد موسكو انضمام
ميلسك الى الصراع في حال قامت
اوكرانيا بغزو بيلاروسيا. ليطالب
زيلنسكي بتعجيل الدعم الغربي
والمساعدات العسكرية. لكن
المستشار الالماني اولفشولز يرفض
تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات نيوبر تو
قبل التشاور مع الولايات المتحدة
وذلك من المواجهة المباشرة مع
روسيا. فبماذا ستشير عليه واشنطن
وكيف ستجيب واشنطن والبنتاجون
اساسا يرفض ارسال القنابل او
الصواريخ او القذائف بعيدة المدى
لاوكرانيا وذلك بحسب فورين
بوليسي. برغم ان اوكرانيا قد
تعهدت مرارا وتكرارا بعدم اطلاق
صواريخ او قذائف قدمتها الولايات
المتحدة وحلف الناتو على الاراضي
الروسية في خطوة المسؤولون
الامريكيون من انها قد تؤدي الى
تصعيد الحرب بينما لا يرى
البنتاجون ضرورة في ارسال قنابل
صغيرة القطر الى اوكرانيا ايضا
لان تجميعها سيستغرق وقتا طويلا.
الصين اكبر معوقات واشنطن. الصين
اصبحت شوكة في حلق امريكا. فلا
الامريكان استطاعوا بلعها
والتخلص منها ولهم استطاعوا
اخراج من حلقهم. والحقيقة انهم
لن يستطيعوا ايضا ان يبقوا الوضع
على حاله. فهون وزير الدفاع
الامريكي لوريد اوستن يقول ان
الولايات المتحدة تدعم سياسات
الامن القومي الياباني. ويؤكد
التزام واشنطن بالدفاع عن
اليابان بما يتضمن الردع النووي.
بينما اكد الرئيس بايدن ايضا ان
بلاده ملزمة بالتحالف مع اليابان
ليرسم الرئيس الامريكي مع رئيس
الوزراء ياباني كيشيدا خطة تسليح
تاريخية لمواجهة المخاوف
المشتركة بشأن الصين. ليأتي الرد
الصيني فورا حيث انتقدت الخارجية
الصينية تصريحات واشنطن وطوكيو
التي تقول ان الصين هي التحدي
الاستراتيجي الاكبر في المنطقة.
مضيفة ان على امريكا واليابان
التخلي عن عقلية الحرب الباردة.
توتر كوري من طرف واحد. تهافتت
الصواريخ وانهالت القذائف
وازدادت الخروقات ليعيش جيران
كوريا الشمالية الرعب بذاته على
وقع التوتر مع جارتها. بدأت
كوريا الجنوبية مناورات عسكرية
مشتركة مع الولايات المتحدة. حيث
تعتبر واشنطن ابرز حلفاء السيول.
وتم نشر ما يقارب ثمانية وعشرين
الف جندي امريكي لحماية كوريا
الجنوبية من جارتها النووية
الشمالية. وكانت المندوبة
الامريكية لدى الامم المتحدة
ليندا توماس جرينفيلد قالت ان
كوريا الشمالية انتهكت عددا
كبيرا من قرارات مجلس الامن
الدولي باطلاقها غير القانوني
تسعة وستين صاروخا بالستيا خلال
العام الماضي. وحذرت جرينفيلد من
استعداد كوريا الشمالية لاجراء
تجربة نووية سابعة منتقدة دور
الصين في الحماية الدبلوماسية
لبيونج يانج. تركيا في مفترق
طرق. المفاوضات جارية والشروط
مجابة والسويد تقبل بشروط انقرة
حتى تنضم للناتو، ولكن فجأة
وبدون سابق انذار. تم تعليق دمية
لاردوغان اثناء زيارته العاصمة
السويدية، وذلك ربما يعرقل
انضمام السويد للناتو. ليقول
وزير الخارجية التركي مولود
جاويش اوغلو ان استهداف انصار
حزب العمال الكردستاني للرئيس
التركي في ستوكهولم جريمة
كراهية. مشيرا الى ان السويد
كانت قد تعهدت بمنع حدوث ذلك
وعليها ان تفي بوعودها. تركيا
ربما تحقق احد اهدافها. لكن في
مكان اخر حيث قالت ادارة جو
بايدن انها ستطلب من الكونجرس
الموافقة على بيع طائرات اف ستة
عشر لتركيا لتحديث قوتها الجوية
بعد فشل صفقة شراء اف خمسة بحسب
اما في سوريا فتستمر الاحتجاجات
للاسبوع الثالث على التوالي
تحديدا في الشمال السوري وذلك
رفضا لتقارب تركيا مع نظام
الاسد. الاحداث والتطورات. بعد
مباحثات اولف شولدز مع رئيس
الوزراء العراقي محمد شياع
السوداني قال شولز ان العراق قد
يكون شريكا مهما لبلاده في مجال
الطاقة ينقذ الغاز العراقي
المانيا من الغرق اكثر بازمة
الطاقة. غضب واسع في امريكا بعد
وفاة شاب اسود عذبته الشرطة
بالمسدس الكهربائي. وزير
الخارجية الايراني عبدالهيان
هناك اتفاق على استمرار الحوار
السعودي الايراني. الجيش
اللبناني يطلق النار على مسيرة
اسرائيلية اخترقت المجال الجوي
اللبناني. مظاهرات حاشدة في تونس
تطالب برحيل الرئيس تيس عيد
مرددة الشعب يريد اسقاط النظام.
روسيا تشعل غضب الناتو والصين
تجعل امريكا تستشيط غضبا. فلمن
ستؤول الكافة برأيكم.